well the way kova 19 is being handled is
now changing here in nevada
more control is now going back to the
county level the state's covet
mitigation task force just gave an
update earlier this morning
bianca holmen live in the newsroom with
what they discussed hi bianca
we've actually reached several
milestones in the fight against the
coronavirus
now more power is going back to local
governments to help fight the spread
so here goes some details starting may
1st some authority will be transitioning
from the state's task force
to the local counties but first the
local governments they must submit their
plans clark county representatives say
that
their team will meet weekly and the
southern nevada health district will
make guidelines based on various factors
like positivity rate and death rate
and those involved in making those
decisions include the health district
ccsd superintendent
the nevada hospital association and
others billy samuels with the clark
county covid 19 task force says the
valley
call center and various associations are
helping to spread the word about the
vaccine
if you're asking what we want down here
in the south our ppu is great our
resources are great but if you guys can
get us vaccines
um to get us to our 1.2 million to that
60 percent of our total population
we can get out of this whole lot quicker
so that's my ask from you guys into the
state
and so far it looks like we're in line
with the federal goal to have the
vaccine available to all adults by may
1st and we're ahead of that with the
vaccines
being offered to those 16 and over
starting april 5th and as far as the
mitigation plans counties must have them
submitted to
the uh federal to our state government
excuse me by mid-april and shortly after
that we'll have a better understanding
and idea
on how those restrictions that are in
place now will be lifted
bianca holman 8 news now